hello everyone and welcome back to the
good stuff we are continuing our 1858
match between paul charles morphy and
the yohanyako bloventhal
uh and like we said lemental is trying
to avenge his uh
loss uh from the 1850 uh where he lost
to the 12 year old morphy and he's not
doing all that great we're gonna skip
game three
as it was a bit of a snooze fest uh
morphe with the black pieces to grind
out uh
a a nice victory but it took him some 90
moves so i thought you guys might
want to skip that one uh but this is a
game four
and it again features uh the very nice
kings gambit morphe employed in game two
and if you remember uh we've
covered that game in the previous video
morphe really struggled and it was uh
well
logan tell basically defeated himself i
mean he was awarded the barnes head for
his attempt
uh but in this game morphe improves on
his opening a little bit so let's see
what happens here
and before we check out the game i would
just like to uh
invite anyone who's interested there is
a very nice article
it's the first link in the description
below by manu guru
uh for chess based india regarding what
uh really happened
in the match india versus russia and
this that entire
uh uh well sort of scandal that happened
uh and uh well regarding india versus
mongolia and
regarding the entire event and regarding
the uh issues they had with
with their internet so do check it out
it's a very thorough very detailed
if you guys are into that now let's get
back to the match
uh so morphe again opens with e4 and we
have e5 like in game two knight f3
sorry knight not knight of three already
said was the king's gambit so f4 the
king's gambit is on the board
uh and bishop to c5 so love intel liked
his position he got in uh game two so he
repeats everything
uh knight f3 we have d6 and c3 now again
not going for kings evans here
we have c3 and bishop to g4 and in game
two murphy went for bishop to c4
which is very active but he very very
quickly got into a really bad position
so here
he plays a bit more timid he plays
bishop to e2 and now the knight is in
pin so already there's the threat of
capturing
on e5 uh so of course uh elemental
captures on f3
we have bishop captures and knight to c6
he just continues development now b4
challenges the bishop we have bishop to
b6 and b5 as well
getting rid of the knight as white
really wants to play d4 so you need to
get rid of one of
the defenders of the d4 square we have
knight c to e7 and now
d4 so morphe with full control of the
center is now ready to
enjoy his position and castle with e
captures on f4
finally accepting the king's gambit and
it is as of move nine that this position
never
happened again uh we have bishop
captures on f4 and now
knight to g6 uh remaneuvering the knight
attacking the bishop bishop back to e3
helping out with with the defense here
and knight to f6 now elemental ready to
castle we have
knight to d2 uh adding another defender
to d4 pawn and the both players castle
here we have castles castles
and h6 now taking away the g5 square
from
morphy's bishop we have a4 now preparing
a5 which
which is a very nice threat as the
bishop would be trapped so here lemental
plays
c6 uh frees the c7 square for his bishop
and the queen to e2 now morphy develops
the queen connects the rooks and adds
more uh the
protection to the b5 pawn rook the e8
now with more pressure on the e4 pawn
and the queen to d3
just nicely defending that pawn and here
we have d5
so of course elemental would be very
happy to trade off some points in the
center
but morphe would definitely like to keep
it closed as he wants to start attacking
on the king's side so e5 here
challenging the knight knight to d7 and
here morphe goes for bishop to h5 and
it's a very nice move
uh as it comes with temple there's just
the threat of bishop captures on g6
and also you you free up the rook maybe
a nice rook lift will will be possible
maybe you can bring an artwork into the
game
however this bishop to h5 move allows
luintel a very nice defensive idea
so even pause the video here and try to
find this move
while i give you a couple of seconds
uh so for those of you who were able to
do it congratulations on spotting a
really really
really strong uh defensive idea and for
those of you who just want to enjoy the
show
uh give me just one second here
realized i forgot to update the
interface uh
sorry about that that's
not by him
sorry sorry about that
there we go i i left uh i just left the
name up there
so yeah there we go nicely done
all right so for those of you who just
want to enjoy the show uh
congratulations on finding
knight d captures on e5 and it's a
really strong
idea because the bishop controls this
diagonal and also
uh well now you just added another
defender to the knight here so what you
could
do is you could capture it uh you should
go queen to f5 that's what you should do
uh with the threat of this uh just being
captured but
what you really want to do is get your
queen out of harm's way and if the
knight moves you already have a very
nice threat
on the f7 pawn however the point is if
uh this is played then you get the rook
captures on e5
and then if bishop captures on b6 you
get queen captures and b6 with
check and once you move the king now you
recapture the piece
and now everything is everything is nice
as
well you've recaptured the piece and you
will enjoy a very nice position you are
up to pawns and well if anything black
at least
equalized here so while white will have
a very nice attack for example queen f3
going after the rook and the f7 pawn
uh but you can go rook to g5 give up the
f7 pawn and
black continues the game very nicely
there there are no
actual dangers here so uh this is it was
a very nice idea however uh logantel
played rook to e6 he added a defender to
the knight here
but now it's actually uh morphy who has
a winning position rook to e6 loses the
game on the spot
but it's not again not an easy move to
find uh whether morphe founded or not
we will find out after you pause the
video and try to find now a winning move
for morphe
while i give you a couple of seconds
so for those of you who are able to do
it congratulations on spotting this
well incredible idea and for those of
you who just want to enjoy the show
it's rook captures on f7 but not just
yet before playing rook captures on f7
you have to play a5 so a5 is the actual
winning move here
rook captures on f7 is nice however if
you play rook captures on f7 right away
love intel still gets to exploit the
bishop being on this diagonal so you can
go knight d captures on e5 now and now
you attack the queen and the rook here
so again it's the same idea you if you
capture the knight then you go into
knight captures again with a double
attack here queen f5
and now bishop captures an e3 with check
king h1
and now rook the e7 getting the rook out
of harm's way
rook captures queen captures and black
has a very enjoyable position here
what you actually want to do after this
uh well sort of rook captures an f7 idea
knight captures on d5 immediately go
queen to f5
and now you have to give up the rook on
f7
queen captures on e6 and now queen e7
offering a queen trade
because if you go after the if you go
after the knight
then uh black wins the bishop with check
and if you trade queens then the knight
is no longer under attack here
and everything is fine so this is uh
what
what uh could have happened if morphy
played uh
well real captures on f7 right away but
morphy finds a5 and he realizes that
this bishop on this diagonal uh is
simply too strong of a defensive
resource so a5 by morphe with bishop to
c7
and only now rook captures on f7 and now
uh things are a bit different because
you don't really
have a bishop here so any knight
captures here can just be met with pawn
captures you don't really care
so king captures on f7 and now queen to
f5
check first first getting the king away
from the defense either of the knight
or the rook here so if you move the king
then uh
queen just wins the rook so you have to
guard the rook but now bishop captures
on g6
already threatening queen to f7
checkmate so here
queen the g8 by elemental if you go
queen to f8 which seems like a
a better defensive resource it is as it
offers a queen trade you just move the
queen and then rook to f1 will kick away
the black queen
so the black queen doesn't really get to
stay on the f file so after this
bishop captures on g6 with uh queen to
g8
guarding against checkmate and now
bishop to f2 now morphy shifts the
bishop over here
uh uh well to finish the job so
here comes knight captures an e5 you
have to play something
either this or maybe rook captures and
g6 was an option
uh just trying to give your king some
some breeding squares
so the characters on e5 and only now
rook to f8 but now
uh other than rook to f8 there really
aren't any good moves here you could go
for rook captures here but it doesn't
really help you bishop
to h4 will come and then it's just you
you don't really have any good squares
for example rook captures bishop to a4
check
and where is your king gonna go if king
the d6 you can even just play this and
the bishop i mean just completely
winning
so what happened here after d captures
on e5 rook to f8 was played but now
morphy just strikes from the other side
instead of this check morphe gives this
check
and now the rook falls as well so you
can see this game completely opposite of
what happened in the game too
even though morphe played the exact same
king's gambit with that
okay different bishop to e2 instead of
bishop to c4 but in that game lorenthal
was all over the board and
uh in this game he's just nowhere
nowhere to be found
so king d8 was played and morphe of
course grabs the rook bishop captures
so again what do you play even ideas
like bishop to h7 are here
which you know really really put some
problems for for your queen as the rook
will fall
so here rook captures on e5 getting the
queen out of the way but just
queen f2 uh not much for low enthalpy to
do
queen to e6 uh trying to put some
resistance attacking the bishop maybe a
nice rook lift will be possible but not
just b6 morphe just doesn't care
we have a captures a captures and here
well if you go rook
bishop here then rook to a8 is extremely
strong
there's uh not much you can do here i
will show one line as it's really really
interesting for example
rookie one check you can block with the
knight and now you have to guard the the
bishop so if you move the king
now comes the incredible queen captures
on e1 even
ideas like these are in the position uh
queen captures and now bishop f5 check
king the eighth and rook captures is
checkmate
the two bishops cover cover this and of
course the pawn covers this so there's
uh nowhere for the black king to go to
so after a captures on b6 we have queen
to g6
uh logan paul tries the the last
resource trying to trade off some pieces
with b
captures on c7 with check king captures
and here morphy just played
rook to b1 and it was in this position
on move 31 that
uh johanna akulontal resigned in the
game as
there is nothing more to be done here
morphy is uh threatening to jump in with
queen to b6 and while you could
uh prolong the game there is really not
all that much to hope for
uh morphe is up two pieces and luintel
has no
no attack whatsoever happening so yeah
here he resigns and
morphe uh uh wins the game four which
means that
uh first game was drawn and then morphy
won three in a row so
eleventh not doing all that great in
trying to uh
you know avenge his loss from the from
their 1850 match
uh so yeah uh that's uh the game i do
hope you enjoyed it uh i would like to
thank
goku g sarah jones larson grant mcgregor
stephen jaffe and
mario fabri for contribution to my
channel thank you a lot i really
appreciate it
as usual you can check two of my
previous videos here thank you for
watching and i will see you soon
continuing the coverage of the morphe
saga
checking up on your wonderful
suggestions and whatever else happens in
the chess world
thank you all i will see you soon and
have an excellent rest of your day